I spent eight thousand dollars on
Apple's new Mac Pro and after testing it
for the last week and comparing it to
the Mac Studio and to my Intel Mac Pro
this was a mistake now I'll explain why
to you guys the obvious part is that the
Mac Studio is out but there is more than
that and my general review of this
system now taking it out of the box it
is the best unboxing experience ever
that box alone weighs 35 pounds you have
these super high quality handles that
are just weird to have on a box the
packing is incredible and yes this comes
with a keyboard and a mouse that you
don't get with any other desktop Mac now
I own the Intel version of this Mac Pro
since it launched in 2019 and I recently
sold it before this came out finally
dropping the price selling it for four
thousand dollars when it costs 15 new if
you got the Ram from Apple which was
crazy and now I kind of wish that I
didn't now the main reason why I ordered
one of these after Apple announced and
showed us that at the same M2 Ultra as
the Mac Studio is for those PCI slots
and the ability to use this as both our
main video editing computer and a high
capacity full SSD storage that is built
inside of there and that is because it
uses PSI Express 4.0 and I can use one
of these crazy high capacity cards and
get 26 000 megabytes per second now that
is overkill but it is future proofing
and has that capability but what Apple
didn't tell us is that the PC Express 4
bandwidth is actually shared between all
of the slots which means if you put in
multiple cards you get split bandwidth
bringing it back down to PCI Express 3
speeds and that means I could have kept
my Intel version and if I had multiple
cards I would still get the same
performance and that is a bummer now
people are saying that Apple basically
just took the easy way out we know they
were developing the extreme chip they
were developing multi-cards that you can
add in as well and none of that really
worked out so this ends up being
basically a backup plan where apple is
just late on their promise of the
transition period and they just have to
get something out and to prove that
internally the power supply is a
thousand two hundred and eighty watts
and the same exact spec in a Mac Studio
uses less than 300. it's actually 295
Watts if you Max everything out and
you're pulling power from the ports that
is the absolute cap but in reality
maxing out the actual CPU and the
graphics you're sitting more at about
150 so that was reused but the weird
thing is Apple moves some things around
for example the SSD no longer gets
airflow from that side fan it is above
where the RAM used to be and the two
huge lower fans on the system while they
blow into the case at idle speeds but we
no longer have graphics cards like the
Intel version that needed that airflow
it's only you know some PCI slots or
some other cards and then even the top
fan that cools off the GPU the CPU the
ram well maxing everything out I've
never seen it go more than just slightly
above idle basically the lower speed now
one thing that I expect with this Mac
Pro compared to the Mac Studio was lower
temperatures and yes we do in fact get
lower temperatures but very slightly and
on the Max studio you see that even
maxing up with the CPU and the GPU the
heat is only on the back the cooler is
incredible in there and it gets all that
heat out very quickly and on Mac Pro
looking at it the biggest Heat point was
not actually where the CPU heatsink is
it was lower over here on the
motherboard kind of area and with both
fans idle so we don't get any more
performance whatsoever we don't get any
more silentness of the system the only
thing is you get those slots and they
are limited at a price tag of three
thousand dollars more now there is
recently an article put out by The Verge
where different creatives talked about
the Mac Pro and that they don't really
need it not just because the studio but
also because they're preferring just
getting a new Macbook 16 inch because it
performs more than enough and none of
the professionals they talk to only one
person said they're gonna get the Mac
Pro because they don't trust the small
thing talking about the Mac Studio which
of course we have tested and showed you
guys the difference with that the
professionals that needed PCI slots well
they just said that they can get an
external enclosure like this one that
you can get for a couple hundred bucks
and use all the same cars that you can
use inside in one of these for way less
money and I think that is the case for
us as well now we might not get the peak
speeds but those slots are really only
beneficial to those that have PCI
Express 4 cards and pretty much
everything in the market doesn't need it
because we're not using Graphics either
so this is a beautiful heavy system but
now that we tested the Mac Studio and I
did a dedicated video comparing all the
performance aspects of those that you
guys could check out it really does not
make sense to pay that much extra just
for some cards that you can run
externally and then for pcxus 4 well now
we found out that the bandwidth is
limited because they basically just
wanted to make something to make it they
didn't even put multiple controllers in
for those slots now other people also
said that they don't trust apple with
the system because the 2013 trash can
well that was a failure the Intel
version 2019 was supposed to be quickly
updated well we had a couple extra
graphics cards but that was about it and
apple kind of left people in the dust as
well and when they replaced it we got
this again so who knows when they will
update it and it might be more likely
that the new Mac Studio is in fact the
actual Mac Pro that they've always
wanted to make in a small form factor
that they couldn't before with the G4
Cube or the trash can Mac Pro but now
with their own chips they run so so cool
and so quiet that everything finally
works out and the world has moved far
enough from PCI cards or even audio
companies that make cards are now just
making Thunderbolt versions for
creatives as well so this thing that I
bought that I met to keep long term well
it just does not make makes sense and I
think even for us we're going to go with
a different option probably the Mac
Studio the M2 Ultra version because that
thing has impressed us a lot more than
we expected you guys let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below do you think Apple did enough is
this a good system that is worth buying
it looks like the creatives aren't
really agreeing with that the
professionals that usually would buy one
go ahead and click that Circle above to
check out more videos and if you want to
see the full comparison of the studio is
right over there this has been Max and
I'll see you in the next one
[Music]
thank you